The Presidential Commission on the Supreme
Court, which held its final meeting in early
December 2021, was designed to provide
analysis of possible reforms of the Court.
AEI's Adam White was one of the commissioners. The
commission did not take a position on one proposal
favored by many progressives: expanding the court's
membership. What do Americans think?
Americans opposed Franklin Roosevelt's court packing plan
and polls today show more opposition than support — though
responses vary. A September Monmouth University
poll found 58% opposed to expanding the court with
36% in favor. The July Marquette Law School
poll also found more opposition than support.
April polls by Morning Consult and Ipsos/Reuters
found more opposition than support — 46% to 26% in
the former, and 42% to 38% in the latter. In each
case, Democrats were more in favor of expansion
than Republicans. The Reuters/Ipsos poll also found
that 63% supported term or age limits for
the Justices while 22% were opposed.
Doyou think the Supreme Court should be reformed?
And if so, how? Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like andsubscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.